hey thi this is sort of like an exercise
in humiliating futility
uh remember the truckers these these
right-wing truckers who were going to
protest mandates and demand liberty and
all these things
one of the leaders of the right-wing
truckers has been arrested
and he was arrested because he came to
the attention of police while protesting
non-existent coveted mandates you might
be saying wait a second david the
truckers aren't still going are they
because there's no more there's no
mandates there's some industries have
requirement but like what what are we
even talking about when we say covet
mandates things are essentially back to
normal it would be really dumb to get
yourself arrested during a protest for
something that's not even worthy of
protest anymore that's exactly what this
guy did our friend zachary patrizo from
daily beast wrote this article
right-wing trucker's leader gets
arrested while protesting non-existent
covet mandates in dc here is a picture
of david santa riddell if you're looking
at the picture you might understand why
his nickname is santa the leader of the
right wing and covet anti-vaxx 1776
restoration movement former formerly
called the people's convoy was arrested
near the national mall on wednesday
after his group came to town protesting
non-existent mandates far-right proud
boy member and leader david santa
riddell was taken into custody for a
warrant out of maryland
per dc metro police officers he was
placed under arrest for the arrest
warrant that he had issued for him if
there is a warrant out for your arrest
maybe it's not a good idea to get even
more people paying attention to you and
i guess riddell asked police to brief
cameras about what is happening
and they explained what's going on this
is like adding insult to injury you're
protesting something that doesn't even
exist and it turns out he was wanted and
now you get yourself arrested what did
he do
you guys are a disgrace to america
that's what you are as a disgrace to
america
that's
can i speak for a second sure i spoke
with that with uh david over here he
said it's okay for me to share this
information with you
obviously there's problems but he's okay
with that he's being placed under arrest
he asked me to let you know because he
has a warrant for his arrest out of the
state of maryland for obstructing the
railway that's right in the roadways the
metropolitan police department was made
aware of this arrest warrant therefore
we have to take action and execute the
war
by the way
this officer sounds almost apologetic
i don't know if you are getting the same
vibes as me but it's it's sort of
strange
you're not even in maryland
you're not even part of the states
oh that is brilliant you're not even in
maryland and washington dc isn't even
part of the states so um
arrest warrants are interstate and then
extradition from one state to another is
sort of like the next step in a separate
thing but there's really nothing
super controversial outside of these
fringe movements about the fact that
warrants are valid across state lines
constitutional breaking power
there's nothing unconstitutional about
um acting on a warrant from a different
state completely uncontroversial
we're here till he's gone
okay so just just so you understand how
this works since the warrants inside the
state of maryland
you don't get it okay i can't it's not
too far that's five minutes down the
road
it seems like the officer being called a
coward for following the law is
explaining that yes the the warrant is
from maryland but he would now be
x-rated and remember
this this guy is only here
because he's the the arrestee because he
was protesting covet mandates which
don't exist
you are
coward
first amendment protected
for whatever violations occurred in the
state of maryland on apparently july 4th
or 5th a warrant was issued by a judge
in maryland for this individual's arrest
therefore we were notified this warrant
is extraditable he is here we are aware
of it
yeah so that means
we place them under arrest they'll go in
front of a judge here imagine after
having to explain such simple things to
these people such simple uncontroversial
things
he'll be extradited back to the state of
maryland to face those charges okay so
he will not be staying here in dc
eventually he will go back to maryland
in front of a judge eventually
so he will eventually processed here
today in the city he will go see a judge
here depending on how the process works
if he wishes to waive or not waive
extradition then he will go to maryland
and see a judge in maryland no problem
okay that's how the process works
man what what a nightmare i don't even
know at this point what these groups are
trying to achieve because the mandates
are gone yeah they're the defeat the
mandates what mandates are you talking
about um is it a grift for donations and
if so who's even giving to these obvious
scams uh i truly don't get it but really
a self-inflicted self-inflicted
humiliation arrested
while protesting mandates that do not
exist